si yo había sido elegido como el próximo
líder de hong kong el candidato de 64
años era el único en la carrera para ser
el jefe ejecutivo fue votado por un
pequeño comité de leales a beijing
minuciosamente examinado por el gobierno
de los más de 1.400 miembros sólo ocho
votaron en su contra según los
resultados oficiales en su discurso de
celebración y dijo que es una nueva
etapa para hong kong javier néstor con
la restauración del orden a partir del
caos el skytrain
razón como estas ya es hora de que hong
kong inicie un nuevo capítulo de
desarrollo un capítulo que se orientará
hacia una mayor prosperidad para todos
y nos encontramos en un momento de
grandes oportunidades y desafíos
challenges el político leal a beijing
sucederá a la líder saliente carril am
bajo su mandato en 2019 la ciudad vivió
una oleada de protestas prodemocráticas
y fue una figura importante en la
represión de estas protestas como jefe
de seguridad de la ciudad en ese cargo
fue sancionado por eeuu por ayudar a
imponer una ley de seguridad nacional
que sofocó el movimiento democrático de
hong kong como jefe del ejecutivo de
hong kong le ha dicho que quiere
promulgar nuevas leyes de seguridad lo
que hace temer que su liderazgo sea una
señal de que beijing quiere reforzar su
control sobre hong kong su elección le
convierte en el primer funcionario de
seguridad que asume el máximo cargo de
la región tomará posesión el 1 de julio
25 años después de que reino unido
entregara hong kong a china